qué está pasando en chile para que
rechazar la nueva constitución tenga
mayor apoyo cuáles son los puntos más
polémicos
los puntos más polémicos de esta
propuesta de borrador de nueva
constitución tienen que ver con su
historia el proceso constituyente que
duró más de un año fue un proceso que
partió con un gran nivel de apoyo más
del 78 por ciento al igual que el
plebiscito de entrada a este proceso
constituyente donde la opción aprobado
también obtuvo más del 20% había un gran
consenso en el país en avanzar en este
proceso pero el trabajo y la captura por
grupos más radicales del proceso
constituyente terminó que en muchas de
las propuestas más sensibles se alejarán
mucho el sentido como un ciudadano en
chile- y por lo mismo en materias como
pensiones salud vivienda que no les
gustó la propuesta hecha por la
convención y se generaron grandes
controversias ya en el proceso de la
discusión misma de estas demandas
sociales en la convención eso hizo que
cayera abruptamente el apoyo a la
convención que terminó con un apoyo
inferior al 30 por ciento
eso creo yo que fue el inicio de la
difusión del proceso de este borrador de
nueva constitución pero las personas lo
vieron como un continuo el producto de
una mala convención te costó mucho de
convencer a pesar de que un gobierno ha
hecho un gran esfuerzo de que tuviera un
mejor resultado bueno el presidente
boris dijo que si esta carta magna no es
aprobada volverá a empezar el proceso
constitucional seleccionar una nueva
convención redactar un nuevo texto y
volver a plebiscito así cuantas veces
sea necesario realmente esto sería
beneficioso para el país o lo haría
entrar en una espiral
yo creo que los beneficios para el país
contar con reglas de vida en común que
sean aceptadas ampliamente por la
ciudadanía lo que no ocurre con este
texto propuesto por la convención si es
que gana la opción de rechazo significa
que el deseo la esperanza de tener una
nueva constitución sigue vigente de
hecho la campaña del rechazo ha dicho
que rechaza por una mejor es decir
también compromete avanzarás una nueva
constitución pero una mejor redactada
una que se acerque más al sentido común
mayoritario de los chilenos eso creo que
va a quedar reflejado para que se inicie
un nuevo proceso eso sí se requiere de
un nuevo acuerdo entre todas las fuerzas
políticas presentes en el congreso
porque tendría que iniciarse al igual
que éste por una nueva reforma
constitucional aprobada por cuatro
séptimos de los miembros del palabra
bueno y tras la votación de alguna
manera podremos esperar volver a ver las
grandes manifestaciones similares a las
que vimos en 2019
yo creo que no yo creo que parte del
error del texto hacerse cargo de un
clima que vivía en el país no está
presente hoy día lo que hay es un clima
de encuentro es un clima más de
esperanza un clima que quiera avanzar en
reformas pero en reformas que vayan de
la mano de lo que los chilenos
mayoritariamente expresan por lo mismo
de ganar la opción rechazo en chile yo
creo que más que el inicio de una
violencia va a haber una sensación
primero de alivio por no tener que tener
una constitución para la cual la mayoría
siente que no es la que le gusta y poder
avanzar su nuevo proceso yo creo que es
el inicio del nuevo proceso con toda la
experiencia y las lecciones aprendidas
corregir los errores que se produjeron
el primero evitar la captura de los
grupos más radicales podría permitirnos
avanzar en un tiempo corto quizá en
menos de un año hace una nueva
constitución pensando que ese texto de
nueva constitución si es apoyado
ampliamente por los chilenos nos va a
regir no solamente por un gobierno sino
de nuevo a regir por 30 a 40 años el
respecto pues señor miller a usted
muchas gracias por su análisis y por
compartirlo con nosotros 24